i mean
for all you kids out there who uh
can't hit the broad side of a net with a
football
once
or twice
or let's try it again trevor let's see
trevor can you hit the can you for all
you kids out there who have that kind of
accuracy there's hope you can still
become trevor lawrence because that was
trevor lawrence in 2015
missing every on track to become the
number one overall pick in the draft he
had his
shoulder surgery on tuesday the left
shoulder uh and it was a success and
he's already ahead of schedule and uh
unless he isn't who knows but he's still
gonna be the first overall pick the only
question in my mind peter is it going to
be the jaguars who take him or is
somebody going to make the jaguars an
offer they can't refuse to go up and get
trevor lawrence and we were spitballing
about this yesterday wouldn't it be
something if david tepper and the
carolina panthers packaged the eighth
overall pick and throw in a bunch more
stuff
to go up and get trevor lawrence and
keep him in the carolinas
yeah i don't see how it's possible
unless
you know
the only way this is possible is let's
just say that deep down
trent balkey and uh and urban meyer and
the brain trust get to a point let's
just say
a month from now
where they feel
you know mike what happens now is i was
listening to a podcast with todd mcshea
uh
and mel kiper and field yates yesterday
it was really informative about the
quarterback position it was saying where
everybody is right now
and and todd mcshea
has
justin fields fourth in that group of
the four guys
you know of the top four guys
and
so imagine if urban meyer
and they as the draft begins to shake
out
if there is legitimate thought that
justin fields is going to drop maybe
into the middle of the round and again
we we don't know you don't know on
february 17th
what it's gonna be like two months from
now you just simply don't know but
suppose you think that
and then carolina's gonna offer you five
ones for the pick
uh and maybe throw in bridgewater as
your bridge guy
so maybe if you're jacksonville you
consider that but the only way you
consider it
is if you like one of the lesser
quarterbacks
97 as much as you like trevor lawrence
otherwise do not overthink this just
tell all the people who call i can't
hear you
and step up and take uh trevor lawrence
but but the the other side of that
argument is and and it depends upon how
much you're offered i made this case
last year when the dolphins seemed
hell-bent on trying to get joe burrow
from five to one and and in hindsight
you know what the bengals should have
done the bengals should have taken the
offer and drafted justin herbert at
number five
as much as i love joe burrow the gap
between the two isn't enough
that that i'd say okay i still get a
franchise quarterback who by the way
emerged from the season healthy
not that it was joe burrow's fault but i
got all this other stuff too
that see
you you're giving up one guy
in exchange for
x number of guys and x number of
lotteries well it's easy to say that now
it's easy i know
but
i know it is but it proves the point it
proves the point if you trade one
lottery ticket that you think is a sure
thing you're not sure you think it is
after all the surgery was a success
for a bunch of other lottery tickets
maybe you collectively win more
on the other lottery tickets than you do
on the one that you think is a sure
thing that's why i say you don't slam
the phone down you at least listen
because there may be an offer you can't
refuse and you need to be smart enough
to not refuse it
i think the one difference between this
year and last year
is that and look mike we don't know this
right now
because it's so early but
the impression that i get very
preliminary spitballing talking to a few
people around the league and you i'm
trevor lawrence is here
the other three guys are here here and
here in some order that's the impression
you get last year
you you really got the impression that
burrow was here
but that the other two guys were were
close
and some teams might like
uh tua better than burro some teams
might like justin herbert better than
tua let's just say
but
it's hard for me to imagine this year
you know i i would i would also just say
look at this mike
it's 2021 right now
think about 2031
and think about where you will be as a
franchise
if you have the absolute total number
one slam dunk best quarterback in this
draft and you're 10 years down the road
just think for a minute
if instead of having justin herbert who
is on some other team denver carolina
the jets
if you have if you took let's say
trey lance and now you've moved on from
treylands because he was good but he
wasn't great or maybe one of them turns
out to be trubisky i don't know that's
why at the quarterback position
you don't mess around
if you have the chance to take the great
guy the unquestioned guy
you can't find those guys
you got to take them
uh but but but but
and and look this is why the draft is
such a complete and total crap shoot
let's just go back
nine years
it was andrew luck
as the top guy
robert griffin iii not far behind tony
dungy argued at the time he'd have taken
griffin over luck they went one and two
and those were the two and everyone else
was a project or uh who knows or uh
brian tannehill are you kidding me he's
a converted receiver and now look at
where we are
luck retired and you can never factor in
when a guy is going to decide he just
doesn't want to play anymore but it
happened luck's gone rg3 is a backup who
currently doesn't have a team tane hill
holy crap he's making more money over
the first four years of his current
contract than deshawn watson or patrick
mahomes russell wilson who
he went to two straight super bowls and
he's one of the best quarterbacks in the
league and then you got another guy
who's a super bowl mvp it did amazing
the 2012 draft yielded a super bowl mvp
and it wasn't andrew luck and it wasn't
rg3 and it wasn't russell wilson it was
nick freaking foles
so
and you see you just you do my back to
my point
and i know kirk thanks pete kirk cousins
also was drafted that year but but but
which isn't something to gloss over by
the way my point is
if you can take that one
and you can parlay it into
i don't know how many not that it worked
for the rams that's the other side of it
too and i think this is one of the
reasons why the rams are so gun shy
about using first round picks now
remember les sneed's quote to you
dominate with washington's picks they
didn't
they got three ones and a two
for the rg3 pick and it blew up in their
face just the whole thing for all the
money all the time all the obsession and
i guarantee you on draft night peter on
nfl network and espn every guy taking in
round one we're going to hear how great
he is and they're never going to say you
know there's a chance this guy's really
going to suck but the reality is
half of them are really going to suck
it's all one big mess we just don't know
and we may as well plant that flag now
folks before you get all juiced up about
the draft we don't know and we won't
know until 10 years from now
you know here's the other interesting
part of it mike that always fascinates
me
like
this year especially versus other years
and that is
the competition a guy has faced in
college
factoring that into
uh you know what you're going to do in
the draft and so a lot of people like
todd mcshea on this podcast he really
likes trey lance now here's the
interesting thing
trey lance plays at whatever it's called
one double a i call it because that's
what it was called forever you know he
played at one double a where carson
wentz played
but
this year
he played what two games one or two
games
all right
and and then last year you know
obviously had a really good year he
didn't turn over the ball didn't turn
the ball over it was a ridiculous year
but
do you really have as much in him as you
want to see or
do you have to do with trey lance
what bill walsh once did with charles
haley
now you you were you were in uh you were
in short pants at this time mike sort of
but remember
when uh charles haley out of the in the
third round out of james madison
whatever year it was 85 maybe i forget
but he took charles haley and somebody
said to him
how can you take a guy who didn't have a
great college career who played at james
madison and you know i why are you
taking him and he goes because i've seen
him do
what great players in the nfl do i've
seen him do it a few times in college
and if i've seen him do it a few times
now it's our job to keep to coach him to
do it every time
and they ended up coaching him well
enough so that he became a hall of famer
it's the same thing with trey lance but
now with trey lance you don't even have
a last season to really consider you've
got the level of comp thing and you have
this so that is what makes it i'm just
saying mike that's one of the reasons
why
if i've got the first pick in the draft
i'm going i can't hear you i can't hear
you no leave me alone we're taking
trevor lawrence
and so that's why i think this year is
even more difficult to envision a trade
for lawrence
yeah i still think you have to listen
because again someone may make you an
offer you can't refuse and you have to
be smart enough to not refuse it if it
comes along by the way one double a is
now fcs or as i call it one vowel away
from being a filthy word
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports